on the mid-season finale of better call
saul
we need home court advantage i'm gonna
figure out what the hell is happening
howard
did you know that if you google for a
drawing of chamomile the first drawing
that comes up is identical to the image
on the side of howard's tea
and did you know if you googled does
chamomile tea have caffeine you'll find
out the answer is no hey guys pete here
we've made it to the mid-season finale
of better call saul's final season and
today i'm going to preview episode 7.
i'm going to break down the teaser
trailer have a look at the promo photos
where again we get a sneak peek of a
returning character who definitely
didn't deserve what happened there and
all the other stuff that's out there in
the world we can use to think about what
might happen in this episode if any of
that sounds like spoilers to you then
this is your chance to leave and with
that out of the way let's get into it
the title of episode 7 is plan and
execution which we know they've been
putting together a plan over the course
of the season the execution part of that
feels a little ominous if we think about
double meanings last week the and part
was the word grind which was related to
howard grinding the coffee but then also
kim having an axe to grind with him at
the same time does this mean that there
will be a literal execution i mean we
are in the breaking bad universe so
that's always a possibility to risk a
short side track there was this photo
that bob odenkirk posted on patrick
fabian's birthday that caused quite a
stir when fans noticed what looks like
blood in his hair i didn't read too much
into it at the time and largely ignored
the theorizing that happened around it
but it has come to my attention that
howard is wearing this same pink shirt
in episode 7. it might be nothing but i
thought i ought to bring it up in case
you missed that connection the official
summary of 607 is short and sweet and
reads jimmy and kim deal with the last
minute snag in their plant we already
know the snag is the fact that the judge
has a cast on his arm and there are
several shots in the trailer that make
it look like they're doing a last minute
reshoot kim and jimmy are wearing the
same clothes they had on in the final
moments of the last episode which of
course was on d-day and that makes for a
nice race against the clock situation we
see jimmy go to the university to pull
the camera man out of a class that it
looks like he's teaching jimmy
approaches who i assume is lenny at work
the person they hired deposes casemiro
taking the bribe he tells him carpe diem
sees the day don't live with regret it
looks like it's a bit of classic saul
talking him into leaving his post to get
this photo shoot done which it does look
like they do there's a shot of a dark
room and we see the dropper bottle that
they got off the vet coming into play
the dark room indicates that they're
developing the photos and you see that
jimmy's wearing gloves when he's
applying the drops this backs up the
idea that the medication is topical that
it can be absorbed through the skin they
made a point of jimmy saying his skin
was dry where they applied it when he
tested it out in the last episode could
they be putting it on the actual photos
so that when he picks him up he'll get
dosed i really don't know enough about
how topical concoctions you buy off of
shady veterinarian work to say but it's
interesting that they're doing it all
ahead of time there doesn't appear to be
an extra step where they have to have
someone get close to him to use the
drops and in the opening shot jimmy is
still wearing those gloves when he's
running with the envelope that could be
further evidence of this but i suppose
it's also possible that he just might
not have had enough time to take them
off because somebody else is gonna have
to handle this envelope to deliver it to
howard there's really no scenario where
jimmy passes this off to him
i already went over the plan in my
episode 6 recap so i won't go through
the whole thing again but the quick
summary is that they need howard to see
the photos of what looks like jimmy
bribing the judge give him the drop so
he looks high and have him make an
accusation publicly about what he saw in
the photos during the meeting so
everyone thinks he's out of control when
his claims of a bribe turn out to be
false crazy cokehead howard made
everyone look bad let's settle the case
and cut ties before he tanks it
completely the sandpiper residents get
their money jimmy gets his cut and kim
gets to take down howard before using
the money to open a pro bono practice to
help the less fortunate i think all of
this is fairly settled at this point we
talked about it on the live stream and
we're all in agreement about the plan
i'm still not sure if the pi that howard
hired is in on the plan or if there's
something else going on there if they
got to him it would make things work a
lot better it would explain some of the
stuff that felt borderline questionable
in the last episode like them not
worrying about being seen when they had
a drink right outside of hhm the night
before d-day but they would almost have
to show us how they orchestrated that
because it would be difficult for them
to get him to hire the one particular
private investigator they needed him to
in that scenario either way we see the
two sides of the case sit down rich
schweikert and his team on the left hhm
and davis and main on the right what you
don't see in the teaser is that
everyone's favorite class representative
irene landry will be in attendance at
the meeting she shows up in the promo
photos and i gotta say i feel a little
better about what's going down if it
means she's going to get her money after
what jimmy put her through she at least
deserves a happy ending we see glimpses
of the plan unfolding and of course
something has to go wrong there's a shot
of jimmy and kim where i believe they're
listening in on the call because you see
the box for one of his burner phones on
the table he's making a reeling him in
motion with his hands like he's holding
a fishing pole and you can see that this
is making kim smile so at least for a
while they think everything's working
out probably what seems like the most
critical scene in the teaser is also
quick and inconclusive you hear howard
say i'm going to figure out what the
hell's happening you see him turn his
head and i'd like to say the effects of
the drug have kicked in but you can't
really tell he looks at a painting of
chuck and it looks like he has a
revelation is this just him feeling
whacked out or is it him realizing he's
about to fall into a trap after that you
see him running up the stairs and cliff
coming after him calling his name from
the landing i hope i'm not wrong in
thinking he's running towards his office
since i couldn't find any evidence that
it was actually on the top floor and
it's really hard to craft a scenario on
two seconds of footage but if i had to
guess he's just made the accusation and
is now going to get the evidence the
photos which won't be there anymore if
this really is that good of a scam that
would sort of be the ideal outcome for
kim and jimmy alternately he could just
be freaking out from the drug's effects
since they established that he drinks a
non-caffeinated tea perhaps he looked
like a kook he started talking to
chuck's painting and then ran out of the
room because he didn't know what was
happening this would still validate
cliff's concerns which is the goal of
the plan so the outcome would be similar
the problem with either of these is that
jimmy and kim win so there would almost
have to be a fall that follows that i
don't imagine i'm alone in thinking that
whatever goes wrong here will be the
first step in the sequence of events
that explain why kim isn't around and
breaking bad some unintended consequence
has to come out of this meticulously
planned scheme howard could figure out
what they're doing and outmaneuver them
stop the plan from working but there
doesn't feel like there's a conclusion
built into that nothing that we've seen
so far about this back and forth with
howard leads us to believe that it's
gonna be the entire season there's a lot
of other stuff that needs to happen
howard could have an adverse reaction i
don't really think he'll die i'm not
expecting that for the character but he
could or he could have a stroke or
something along those lines maybe he has
a fall he's running around like a
lunatic maybe he falls down throughout
this season the show has been making a
point of trying to make these teasers
tricky making us think something will
happen when it doesn't and i think that
on top of everything else really makes
it impossible to guess but that also
makes it all the more fun i guess the
biggest takeaway i had from this is
we're going to get that payoff for the
last three episodes which were mostly
set up
there's also some gus mike and lalo in
the trailer god seems to be doing some
of the charity work we know he does from
breaking bad it looks like mike takes
him aside and plays him something on a
tape recorder this is a little out of
place but contextually it almost has to
be connected to him finding out what
lalo's up to mike tells him that they
need home court advantage and that seems
to line up with them setting a trap for
lalo where they can control things with
their security team there's a shot of
lalo walking down a hallway with a sign
on the wall which is something i guess
you might see in a truck stop in the u.s
it's for a shower that you can rent for
ten dollars an hour the most interesting
thing is that it's not in spanish or
german and seems to confirm that he's
back in the states which gets me really
excited there's another shot of him
setting a timer and going to sleep in a
car which could be related to this trip
but it almost looks like it still has
that blue german tint they used and i
can't think of a good reason we would
need to see any more of his time there
so i'm hoping this is all in the u.s too
there's only one completely random shot
of binoculars that look like the same
ones kim used in episode 1. there's also
a promo photo of hector on the phone
which you would guess might be lalo
telling him about his plan to get proof
but who knows someone's going to call
hector on the phone and that's pretty
much it peter gould did say this episode
would end with a pretty major
cliffhanger so we have that to think
about during the break i think it's
worth mentioning again that they didn't
write the season in two parts i'm
expecting this to be a better place to
break than at the end of episode six
which if you think about it would have
been pretty bad but i'm trying not to
have too crazy of an expectation that
everything is going to get wrapped up or
something like that going into the
second half which is going to be
completely different and i do think
there's a high likelihood that we'll see
the walt and jesse appearance in this
episode not because of anything that was
on imdb or any of that but it just seems
like the perfect time to introduce them
because you would get a lot of buzz out
of it and maybe some people that haven't
been watching will decide to catch up
before the second half of the season
starts if you're going to introduce them
say in a teaser something like a flash
forward before the break seems a lot
better than after thomas schnauz did
write and direct this episode which is a
good sign his last episode was 509 with
that famous kim and lalo showdown and he
usually does important ones and i think
that's a good place to leave things
let me know what you think will happen
in the comments and how you think things
will go wrong for kim and jimmy please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon